من المعروف النظيف في المناعه معرضون
للامراض وبات لدينا اليوم دراسه الشامله
حول مناعه سكان الشرق الاوسط هذه الدراسه
تظهر نتائج لافته جدا البيانات عن ضعيف في
المناعه في العالم العربي غير متوفره ما
يترك الملايين منهم وغردان الخطر بحسب
الدراسه التي نستضيف اليوم الطبيب الذي
اجرها الدراسه الجديده التي تحمل اسم
المرضى المنسيون تهدف الى توفير حمايه
افضل للمرضى المعرضين لمخاطر عاليه في
المستقبل تعد هذه الدراسه الاولى من نوعها
في المنطقه نتعرف على ابرز ما خلصت اليه
قسمت دراسه المرضى المنسيون ضعيفي المناعه
الى فئتين الاولى اضطراب العوز المناعي
الاوليه وينتج عن عيوب في تطور الجهاز
المناعي ويظهر هذا النوع لدى الاطفال
غالبا ينتشروا اكثر في المناطق التي ترتفع
فيها معدلات زواج الاقارب لذلك يزيد ب 20
مره في منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
اما العوز المناعي الثانوي يظهر عندما
تثبت عوامل خارجيه الجهاز المناعي ووظيفته
الطبيعيه منها مرض السرطان وعلاجاته
وامراض الكلى المزمنه وفايروس الايدز لهذا
يتزايد عدد مرضى السرطان في بلدان الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
بمعدلات مقلقه في ظل توقعات بتضاعف عددهم
تقريبا بحلول 2030 كما يقدر الاتحاد
الدولي للسكري ان اكثر من 70 مليون شخص في
المنطقه مصاب بالسكري وهو اعلى معدل
انتشار لهذا المرض في العالم كما يؤثر
الفشل الكلوى على 100
و87.000 شخص تقريبا في مختلف بلدان
المنطقه ويعد الذين خضعوا لعمليات زرع
اعضاء من اكثر فئات المرضى ضعي في المناعه
عرضه للخطر اما بالنسبه لانتشار فيروس نقص
المناعه البشريه ف- تعد منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا من مناطق العالم
القليله التي تشهد زياده سريعه في
الاصابات بهذا الفايروس حيث ازدادت بنسبه
31% منذ عام 2001
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا عبر الزوم البروفيسور حميد
الشامسي رئيس جمعيه الامارات الاورام
ومؤلف مشارك بالتقرير اهلا بكم بروفيسور
يعني نتحدث عن ارتفاع غير مسبوق في عدد
المصابين بضعف المناعه في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط والشمال افريقيا هل من احصاءات
محدده ومن هم اكثر الفئات المتضرره
السلام عليكم
احصائيات واضحه للمرضى الذين اليوم مصابين
بنقص المناعه في منطقه الشرق الاوسط ولكن
هذه الدراسه بدات تصديق الضوء على هذه
الفئه المنسيه
بامراض السرطان الدم والمرضى الذين خضعوا
لزراعه اعضاء ايضا هم بيستخدموا ادويه
تؤدي الى يعني تثبيت المناعه وهؤلاء كلهم
يعني معرضين لخطر الاصابه بفيروسات
وبكتيريا كثيره وطبعا احنا في ظل الجائح
العاديه
نعمنا في منطقه الشرق الاوسط والشمال
الافريقيه تحديدا ارتفاع عدد الاشخاص
المعرضون الاصابه بعدو شديد وغير قادرين
على تكوين مناعه قويه رغم التطعيم ما
السبب في ذلك
طبعا الاشخاص اللي ذكرناهم الذين هم
بدينهم ضعف المناعه لما تعطي الشخص
الطبيعي تلقيح او لقاح الحب 19 فالجسم
يقوم باصدار او او يعني انتاج الاجسام
مضاده ولكن هذه هذه الفئه المصابون بنفس
المناعه او النزول في المناعه الجسم لا
يستطيع انتاج هذه الاجسام مضاده سيكون
القدره لديهم على مكافحه البيوصلات بشكل
عام وخاصه الكبدنا 19
اقل من الاشخاص العالميه الطبيعيه وهذا تم
الاشتراك في مجلات علميه كثيره جدا وهو
معروفه لدينا في المجال الطبيعي طب ما هي
الاستراتيجيات الواجب اتخاذها بروفيسر
لحمايه المصابين المنسيين المرضى المنسيين
الذين يملكون ضعفا في المنام
نعم طبعا احنا معظمنا الاشخاص الذين بصحه
طبيعيه رجعوا الحياه الطبيعيه ولا اكل في
المنسيه هي الفئه لاصحاب المناعه المنخفضه
عند الاشكاليه في الرجوع للحياه الطبيعيه
مازال مستمرين بلبس الكمامات ولكن هناك
دراسات تمت يعني على هذه الفئه وهناك
ادويه خاصه هي ليست لقاءات ولكن هي عباره
عن ادويه خاصه باجسام مضاده تقوم برفع
اجسام مضاده في جسم الانسان المصاب بهذه
امراض التي
تصيب الشخص لما تؤدي الى نقص المناعه
فيكون عنده حمايه من مرض الكبدعه عشر طيب
نقص البيانات الشاملهم في منطقه في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط والشمال افريقيا الى اي مدى
هذا خطر ويترك الملايين منهم في حاله ضعف
نعم طبعا مثل ما ذكرنا الهدف من هذا
التقرير والتصديق الضوء كخطوه اولى على
هذه الفئه المنسيه ولكن باذن الله احنا في
يعني نقوم ايضا
بمحاوله جمع معلومات اشمل عن هذه الفئه
حتى نقوم بتصديق الضوء عليها وايضا زياده
الوعي وايضا عمل بطولات خاصه بمتابعتهم
وعلاجهم شكرا جزيلا لكم بروفيسور حامد
الشمس
بهذا التقرير شكرا جزيلا لك